[Music]
Tim Tebow
yeah Tim Tebow tweeted this I'm now a
high profile New York sports figure I
can't wait to find a hot model
girlfriend to not have sex with
lady gaga tweeted this someday I'd
really like to settle down and have a
couple of kids to wear as earrings Rick
Santorum tweeted this porn it up fellas
because if I'm elected you'll be
spanking it to the bras section of the
Sears catalog and that Indian chick on
Land O'Lakes butter he's got that bought
oh yeah she's hot Joan Rivers Joan
Rivers tweeted this cold in Hollywood
today got to get fleece injected into my
face Disney Pictures tweeted this sorry
about John Carter but we think you'll
love our new movie about a
time-traveling vampire
it's called Dave whittling
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow Hey Joe Biden tweeted this got booed
for six straight minutes at yesterday's
rally got booed five minutes today
they're starting to come around Lenny
Kravitz tweeted this acting in the
Hunger Games was fun but it's time to
get back to my first love recording the
same song over and over again la Bamba
tweeted this hey computer can you take
these words I am putting into you and
turn them into a churro I like churros
okay bye computer
[Music]
he's a child
and finally my ability he doesn't even
know he's on TV right now it's like when
you see a kitten in a commercial and
finally Steve Tyler tweeted this they
say after a wild couple start to
resemble each other but I don't remember
marrying
[Applause]